[Music]
we probably talk about the movie back to
the future too often on the show i would
say it comes up a lot
and i think one of the reasons i love it
so much is because like a lot of people
i am fascinated by the idea of time
travel if you could go back if you could
change the past if you could
change the future where would you go i
think what would you do go back or
forward uh i i would go back you would
yeah i have one particular regret i
think i would that well you'd go back to
your own life you wouldn't go back
before you were alive is that narcissism
it is pretty narcissistic
that because that's what i i'm concerned
mostly about my own life i hate to say
it now it sounds narcissistic yeah when
you frame it that way i mean i'm
interested in other
things and other moments in history of
course i'd like if i as long as i settle
this one thing
and square that away and and uh don't
have to have regrets about it then
i think i would like to go back to other
periods where would you go back uh i
would go
before i was born but really yeah but
what one of my new year's resolutions
this year was to be more present
so
um sorry i shouldn't even be talking
about this i'm going to reject the
premise
okay well that's very i don't want to go
that's very present
machine so you must be excited for this
present moment of the show sure let's do
it life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short
presently i'm your host justin long life
could be a dream
[Music]
with me as always is my brother
christian currently and present how is
embracing the presence going for you
it's pretty good you know with the time
travel thing i definitely wouldn't want
to go
into the future at all you know both
have to not wanted to go into the future
if you had access to a time machine yeah
at all because it's scary and i wouldn't
want to i both wouldn't want to know i
know what um especially the way it might
be like happening in a bad way uh-huh
but then on the flip side if it's if i
go into the future and it's really good
then i'm going to be jealous that i
don't that i won't get to exist in that
time so well in either if it's good or
bad i don't want to see it right
presumably if you were there and you
were witnessing it that means you could
exist in it no if you have a time
machine i'm assuming you can't just go
to the future and live in the future i'm
assuming it's like a safari a visiting
situation and in the past
i wouldn't want to go back to a previous
time in my life because i feel like that
would only exacerbate any regret i had
and if i wouldn't be able to do anything
about it anyway it might be kind of
depressing
to witness it again i wouldn't want it
the only thing i'd want to do is go way
back way way way better before i was
born
but but then the downside to that is
it's potentially dangerous and i might
get you know yeah i mean in any
period in history so i don't want to go
in the times especially with our
lineage i don't think we were like we
weren't like aristocracy no we were like
roman guards we weren't from uh that
kind of stock and we weren't from a
wealthy line i don't think so it's not
like we would go back and be protected
but here's the thing we survived our
line
however much we want to look down on it
we were from a privilege we survived
lines so it must have been a pretty good
line we must have had something that
made us survive as a as a
family yeah certainly biologically we
had a
something was healthy enough to keep
going i mean we have two grandmothers
who are 103 104 104 103. i feel like
we're sneaky people
you know
like we've we've uh
yeah we got out of like we just like
weaseled out of things
that's not good
um well why are we talking about time
travel presently we're about to hear
from
i guess being present doesn't just mean
keep using present in some form in your
space if that's what it means to you
then that's okay that's not what my
resolution was about no i want to be
more present too i think it's a good one
because
the reason that i'm into this moment in
my past is like you know it's because i
have a uh something i want to change and
that's not good that's not a way to live
to be pressed because i can't change it
you can't change that i'm dying to know
what you want to change well i'll tell
you later um
anyway
aren't you more dying to know who the
guest is uh yeah can i tell you who it
is yeah he is the star
of a movie and a sequel of a movie
called hot tub time machine oh craig
robinson and hot tub time machine 2 oh
adam's gone no close warm you're warm
dark greg very warm um
clark duke clark duke what'd i say clara
correct yeah some clark uh no our guest
is rob cordrey yes the great the one of
my favorite pals rob cordray from back
in the day how long has it been um that
i've known him 15 years i don't know a
long time you met doing a movie right it
was originally called patriot bill we
talked a little bit about this we've
talked about this show
and probably more than we've talked
about it to more people than definitely
more people who've seen it than who have
seen it maybe um and i bet it's actually
inspired some people to see it oh i
wonder it's actually not that bad of a
movie no it's just a horribly titled
movie yeah it's got now it's called
taking chances if you'd like to take a
chance and see it no no taking chance
taking checking chances
they chose that name over some other
contenders like uh
the plot unfolds uh characters do things
wonder what's next events happen things
in the present characters interact
that's good that was a good one
anyway rob is uh okay it was so fun
doing that with him and our friend kier
who we definitely mentioned a lot but um
we just had such a blast shooting down
in south carolina and and friend of the
show emmanuel sri yes shrieks and hope
hopefully future guest uh as well nick
offerman yes there's an offerman out to
him
to do to do it
did you hear what i said yeah it's funny
you rolled your eyes
like what i can't believe you came out
oh yeah like well it was like an
impressive eye roll
uh anyway rob boston zone
i thought you're gonna say one of the
baldest
one of our baldest guests he is ever had
i mean he is who's balder than that on
life for sure i mean he's so bald that i
it's hard for me to imagine him not
being bald that's how long he's been
bald in my experience
and i think in his i think the way he's
even when he was talking about he's one
of those bald guys that can like he
doesn't seem at all right well he's
subconsciously he looks like one of
those guys who started balding in like
the ninth grade as soon as like the the
day after they started puberty
uh it started going who mentioned that
that they did they went through that was
joel mchale
early but like i feel like rob was
probably bald i knew a few bald kids in
college like baldwin kids um but anyway
he's obviously a lot more than that's
really neither here nor there no no but
it's now here because we're in the
present that's right so uh presently
let's get listening
to i that was my resolution was was come
up with better ways to say oh let's
produce let's let's hear one um
so so
so lay your ears on this you're trying
to come up with a new catchphrase yeah
how to introduce the guests yeah so uh
let me toss rob cordray drop an ear bomb
on you right now yeah
i hope you're all sitting down so that i
hope you're getting your ears waxed and
ready you're waxing down your earboard
your your holes
for robert cordray
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again so we'll meet again
[Music]
i'm thinking about you and curb
that great episode of oh yes oh god
i mean to say a great episode of curb is
like that already that's like that's
every even the mediocre ones are great
um
but were you were you directed that way
were you instructed to play just super
positive that guy super positive that's
it that's the whole thing and my
audition was
and it's the worst because you probably
have gotten these before
like they say don't try to be funny yeah
it just so happened that jeff garland
was coming in right as i was waiting to
go in uh he was like they told you not
to be funny right
i was like
yeah yeah yeah they said don't be funny
and he was like
don't be funny
that's fine just don't and so i went in
and i it's really good didn't try to i
didn't do a [ __ ] funny thing that
whole audition and larry was laughing
his ass off wow i don't know what like
just the reality of what we were doing
because it's absurd yeah it's an absurd
situation and it's it's enough i mean
it's enough that you're especially that
character that like a sex offender yeah
i like that it's not specified what kind
of sex offender he is yeah the
cornucopia of sex offenders you know the
the miasma
of possible sex
and you've played them all
you've listened
you know what i'll keep doing it some
people play the best friend
some people you know they they're the
leading man i'm happy in my drawer well
and you find different shades within the
sex offender rainbow that's the thing
yeah find the shade of the sex offender
yeah i remember it but it's funny with
that episode it didn't really matter it
doesn't really matter it's just the uh
it's the positive he's the greatest guy
yeah hey you're golfing you give him a
golfing tip it's so
good that's such good advice i wonder if
they tell everyone that or or if it was
specific to this character because this
is the kind of thing where you don't
want to
lean on it or you know i've heard that
they tell oh i've heard that they tell
everybody that yeah but that you're
right as an actor it's like especially
somebody who's known for being funny
it's like well how am i going to stand
out there how am i going to well one of
the things i did in the audition was i
was like
we just did the scene where i come up to
him he comes up to me in the parking lot
because i have golf clubs or something
and i said well what's your uh show me
your stance here and i mimed the club
and i was like show me your stance and i
just got behind him
as he was showing me his stance and that
made him laugh like it's not funny yeah
but in the context it's like
well he i heard i heard he
he breaks all the time man which must
feel so good that must feel like oh god
it's like you know making him laugh and
making jon stewart laugh oh it's the
biggest rush ever
yeah so yeah knowing they're both easy
laughs like i'm not like still it
doesn't matter
and then but my fear is that my instinct
would be to because i want their
approval so badly i would i would then
just try to do too much i would just
keep trying to keep going yeah yeah yeah
oh no i do too much i do too much but
you don't i mean that's the thing you
you're really good at censoring yourself
you're really good at story
you're a really good actor so you
understand story how did you understand
how did you come to understand that how
did you
how did you get so good at improvising
how did you unders come to that place
improvising see that improvising was
something that like
i i don't know how good i was compared
to a lot of the people i came up with
like at ucb at ucb yeah like i'm nowhere
near rob hugh bull or
paul sheer or brian husky or any of the
guys that i
but i had like i wasn't i was the only
actor in the bunch like
i went to school for for acting and
and uh you know so i learned to make
choices
in scenes
with my body like rather than saying
things
yeah and stuff like that but the time i
learned if you work at making your scene
partner look good uh and worry about
yourself make your scene partner look
good and you will look good by default
that's so funny rob i was just talking
to vince vince vaughn uh on the show and
he
he said he enjoys setting people up as
much as he he likes taking the ball i i
totally believe that yeah and he's also
uh one who is really satisfying to make
left oh god yeah because he's not an
easy laugh he's not an easy man no but
he has like a kind of
a childish lap he's like yeah when he
goes into that high right just yeah you
know it also just cuts
yeah when i learned that i was like oh
great so the pressures there's there is
less pressure on me i can make my scene
partner look good because i've always
been taught to like in a scene
you know to you always have to get you
know a goal
using the people in the scene you know
that they
and uh and so that that that came
naturally to me and but i also find that
it bleeds into life for me like yeah i
always try and remember this is hard
because i'm still at heart and a
narcissist
but like
we all are i want to remind myself to
like do for others like rather than than
doing for myself like yeah in the same
regard it's i'm not always successful
yeah so was ucb a natural fit for you in
that sense and uh having come from that
acting world did you take to it right
away or was it something that you
uh did kind of as a hobby as a side
thing
while you waited for an acting job no i
took to it right away yeah i took it
right away and i was just starting to do
commercials i think at the time like
maybe yeah just starting to do
commercials
uh so like still temping and like but i
have one foot out of the temping or
restaurant world
and this is in new york in new york yeah
and i took to it right away like i was
really good in
level one
and level two and then level three
is when now you're committed man like
you're on a team you're
you're performing every single night
and
you're in your head then then i was just
terrible this is late 90s rob like uh
yeah 97 98 okay and that's around the
time i think um
i knew nate at williamstown had you had
been at williamstown as well right
yeah i went and i uh yeah i did a ton of
ecstasy there and
oh then i did meet you yeah
yeah there you go i see for some reason
i thought you and nate had done true
west or maybe you were going to do true
we were going to and then like a hot tub
time machine yeah oh that's a funny
thing to do instead of true west i know
right because and also like my agent
said at the time when i he said i was
like i'm gonna tell my agent i'm doing
theater and he's gonna freak out
i'm gonna do this and he said uh oh it's
that's cool we love it we love it when
clients do theater because it's really
easy to get out of
[Laughter]
that's funny i can't judge your agent
they would all say that and sure enough
yeah
machine turned out to be great it is it
is like now can it's lasted and it's
going to be like a it's a comedy it's a
classic it's like it's a
cult yeah it's called hit yeah so it
ended up being like a
smart decision and the thing with true
west you can kind of do it you can't do
hot tub time machine again but you can
do
now
now yeah exactly yeah yeah yeah try and
get hot tub time machine made today
or the stage version
now that
you could based on the play it was the
movie was based on the drama the movie
airplay
yeah
what and that you guys shot that in new
orleans right yeah uh the first one we
shot in vancouver second one in new
orleans yeah was that steep pink
yeah yeah yeah um
and was that a thing where you you read
the script you think this will be a lark
this will be was that a surprise that it
ended up being uh
yeah yeah man i so i got you know this
is back in the day when you used to get
uh scripts in the mail or like delivered
to you at night
remember
yes yeah
and instead of just the email to you
and uh i was shooting a movie in new
york with sam
actually oh and
uh it was called um
a winning season the winning season yeah
that's right i was shooting the winning
season
and i saw one of them was named just on
the binder hot tub time machine and i
was like oh
jesus and i said to sam i was like sam i
found i found our next project together
oh this you know and he laughed and then
i opened it up and on the title page it
said
um hot tub time machine based on the
incredibly true story
that's and i was like oh
they're in on it oh wait a minute okay
let me
uh read this with different guys they
might get it yeah yeah yeah yeah
uh that's funny he uh i i forgot you
were in that with seth herzog um
the winning season yeah i can't believe
we didn't mention that
uh so it was a it was shortly before
that that i had met you but just to go
back a little bit um
in the lateness so the late 90s you're
you're dipping your toes into
smaller acting jobs uh what brought you
to ucb what did you hear about it from a
friend did you just yeah i thought so it
was really hot in new york they didn't
have their own theater they were they
were um teaching and performing out of a
a five-story walk-up in a dance studio
oh wow oh they didn't have the place
yeah in chelsea then no this was in
chelsea but it wasn't uh yeah they
didn't have it yet it was wow i think it
was called uh studio arts doesn't matter
um but i heard that it was
i was in a sketch group i was in two
sketch groups at the time
and i heard
that it was andy richter's sketch group
huh i heard they were great it was andy
richter sketch groups yeah i was like i
love andy richter
and i went to see them and and i saw an
ass cat and it was the original ucb john
glaser yeah adam mckay oh wow i didn't
yeah oh oh my god he's the only reason
he's the reason that i oh because his
he was
i've never seen
anybody improvise like that oh really oh
my god yeah i mean i knew he was good i
knew he was quick on his feet just from
doing little parts in his movie he would
throw he'd throw things out there like
that but
i didn't know he was such a pro i didn't
know that yeah i mean as a performer i
don't know about acting wise but like
you know he but as a as an improv
performer and then their style
he was like ian roberts i don't know if
you know yeah i know yeah and yeah they
call him the machine
oh
because he's he can improvise
he never has a bad scene that's crazy
and uh i saw that and andy richter just
happened to be there at that show
performing
weird um
and so then i was just like i was
[ __ ] in you know because they were
i've nev i've never seen anything like
what what they were doing making
connections you know that's what i loved
about it i love connections and things
yeah yeah and even though you had a
background in sketch and something you
loved this was also like a uh a way to
do that without
the formality without the writing part
uh were you writing on your feed but
then it also like informed my writing a
lot like because writing was a lot like
it like you know you still every scene
that they teach you gotta find a game
and the game is that thing that stands
out that you can keep playing and
building upon and
and when you you find it you relax and
then you just play it and you add to it
you heighten it and writing is the same
way basically
at least writing a sketch you know i
brought that to children's hospital too
you know so every scene is sort of
pushing the story along but there's a
separate thing happening in that scene
that is funny and that's sort of the
game that oh yeah
children's hospital does have a
it's like a hybrid structure of there's
a sketch element and there is no there
is for sure the first season was
basically nonsense it was almost all
sketches oh really yeah
where did that idea come from was that
born out of ucb was that uh or was that
a totally separate thing no i was um
i just moved to l.a i left the daily
show to do this
it was a fox [ __ ] sitcom called the
winner you almost said [ __ ] come on it
was
well they called it the winner which is
a stupid day yeah
you could already hear the critics like
yeah um
the winner more like
but
it's like calling up it's like calling
us sick on the back nine
but yeah right yeah i guess she's not
getting it and the whole story was about
me it was seth macfarlane's first live
action now oh oh oh wow and um so i
thought oh sure thing yeah yeah moved to
l.a with my two month old baby [ __ ] yeah
well yeah that's that's a safe bet i
think so yeah then the writer strike
happened and there was no work and i was
here with a two-month-old and
a rental and unhappy like popping
percocets left and right like just to
get a little bit happy
and then i decided to spend my days
learning
how to be productive isn't it like all
day with a kid isn't it like a
two-month-old isn't it yes yeah i mean
that that was a lot of it too she was a
baby so boy i mean nap time when you
have a baby oh our mutual friend kier
described it to me recently because he
knows two children but um
he's the best he loves you we had so
much fun we'll we'll get to but what he
said when you when you have uh downtime
it's like
do you find this that you get
overwhelmed um
with the time with the amount of time
and then it's like what do i do what do
i do uh i'll watch tv for a little bit
and then it's just like ah there's so
many things now i have an hour and now
it's like yeah yep oh it still happens
i've got a 14 year old and a 12 year old
that basically take care of themselves
like they're done
and
like i still yesterday for the first
time since march they were all out of
the house and i had the house to myself
so i was just like walking through rooms
yeah i was like do oh i think i need the
screen door open
no i'll close it uh
should i oh i'll do this order a pizza
hey
oh
oh watch a scary movie and basically
just i'm watching trailers for scary
movies yeah it was it was a totally
wasted evening it never ends wait so
you're filling your days uh learning to
be productive meaning like i was
spending eight hours a day being
productive
learning about productivity
right that's right it was wild and yeah
and i did how do you learn about
productivity i learned a lot there's
there's a lot of like um this was before
all the to do apps you know and
everything and there is this one system
that a guy named merlin man had sort of
made his own and and
uh it's called get things done gtd
and he had like he sort of hipped it up
and it was really cool and it's all
about just getting everything out of
your head and on paper somewhere in a or
in a on your computer in an inbox like
out of your head
so that's because then make to make room
for ideas and so i learned that i read
the book i listened to everything i
could about it watched everything i
could got everything out of my head
and my daughter
pulled a tendon or what it was like it's
called nurse made elbow
some kids get it uh she comes out of the
the tendon comes out of its out of place
she can't bend
it's incredibly painful and she can't
bend her arm okay so that happened um i
took it a children's hospital which is
the least funny place in the world it's
like with sad patch adam's scared
parents all over the place and yeah it
was like a tv show like this gurney
comes rolling through the double doors
like
with doctors over the
chaos gurney and chaos and an air flight
pilot behind them a life flight pilot
rather and
the only thing i noticed what i noticed
was
that everything like gurney was smaller
and like everything the iv bag was
smaller
and i was like oh this is the worst
place
in the entire world yeah and see only
you see a comedy in that
and on the way home
uh i remember it was i was on larch
months now i was on lar yeah lucerne
street and i was dressed we were driving
near the house and uh and i was like
hey
does this sound like a stupid idea to my
wife like
all the all the sexual
you know politics
of grey's anatomy
but in a children's hospital
and uh-huh and so that was it
that's never gonna work
but she was like you're a [ __ ] idiot
get a job
go to law school all right you're gross
stop taking percocet
what but you were undeterred
um what
did was she into was it like
your wife is i've i know a bit i've met
she's very funny
do you you must rely on that must be a
good sounding board to have oh she's the
best yes yeah and she's super funny you
know yes like and she's gotten funnier
over the years like well she's exposed
she's yes one of the greats yes
um
but like she's so yeah she's so funny
and so then
and and you get your friends to do it
basically you write this thing yeah and
i was like i in this and this became the
mo of the show forever it's like i'm
just going to surround myself with
people that i love the most in the world
that are funny well you mentioned rob
hugh ball
he comes up a lot on the show people
i gotta have him on he's uh yeah one
like you said one of the funniest brian
huskies yeah i just talked to mollyn the
other day ackermann oh yes yeah yeah
yeah she was on the show
like i don't think people think of her
maybe as a really funny person but she's
hilarious she's hilarious yeah yeah and
really
yeah um so i just have been collecting
all these people over the years
and and my manager was like you know you
should talk to david wayne about this
because this sounds like his sort of
brand of comedy and yeah
where does absurdism played very
straight i mean that's the way it works
yeah yeah yes yes yes yes and did david
get it right away did you send him
something to read uh yeah absolutely
yeah and i love it i love that he loved
it you know yeah i bet talk about a
stamp of approval and it's still very
special to him you know i mean he's
yeah it's he's still very involved well
we don't do it anymore but but oh so
he's not involved at all so he doesn't
have i guess i guess he has zero
involved
i mean
uh me too i have i guess
you're still so you're still not doing
it either nobody has any involvement oh
if you want to get involved i'd love to
get involved do any of your listeners
want to get involved
is it so anyone could just kind of get
involved now yeah i guess it's just the
property's just sitting there
you don't own the rights to a children's
hospital i i don't know i don't think
the funny ideas not with my
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and would
shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wonderingplus in
apple podcasts or the wandery app
[Music]
hello hello again
[Music]
have you been writing during this time
rob have you found it like a creative
time during the
not during this weird pen yeah but not
real not not anything not writing
anything like
uh
you know useful or or for our work you
know because also like god everybody's
been writing
i know everything oh there's going to be
like a flood of
yeah i know it's already happening i
guess like
that trash just saw a trailer for us
like michael bay movie about
cove about covid it's like it's about
the pandemic
and like she just called it too soon i i
couldn't believe but it's all really
like
well done you know kind of like you
could tell there's money in it and and
go back no he just ran the numbers he
was like what are people talking about
right now
let's covet what is it what is this
coven 19 thing yeah it's like
it's a it's always a bad disease all
right well let's do a movie about that
because people are
people love disasters i mean look look
the numbers are there
but um speaking of movies that people
love and like surefire hits uh we talk
about my brother and i love to talk
about the movie we did which when we did
it it's called patriot it was called
patriotic patriot bill and i can't
remember what the new wedding
no
here's why you can't remember because
it's maybe the most generic title
forgettable it's very forgettable it's
just uh
it's called taking chances oh
[Applause]
rob rob just threw up oh just so
terrible at least put a z in chances
you know taking chances yeah
yeah spice it up a little bit like an
exclamation point
yeah
a christian said it might as well be
called like things happen
you know
making decisions
people do things and they have
consequences of some sort
um but
that time that was such a fun time it
was a uh yeah that was great
it's great and and i remember when i
heard you were gonna do it uh i was just
such a fan of yours that was just
a great time but we um do you miss that
do you miss like uh
i i do i miss going to like a small town
i probably would never have gone to yeah
yeah yeah and like finding the good
restaurant the one good restaurant there
and like
getting wasted with everybody in the
cast or in the holiday inn yeah
i'm imagining you with like craig
robinson and those hot tub time machines
in new orleans i mean you said the first
one is vancouver but like uh man you
guys in new orleans i spent a day with
craig in new orleans on a job and he's
the mayor of new orleans yes yes and he
sits like a mayor he sits like a king on
a throne this is
so my wife and i my wife was visiting me
and craig was like just texting me like
meet me here and he gave him an address
we went to this the street was dead
and i was like what what the [ __ ] is
this
i don't know where we are
and
uh we're like maybe we should leave
because it was like five minutes late
and then a door opens
and this huge guy walks out of the door
and he's like
you guys here for greg
and we're like yeah
follow me
we followed him to this winding hallway
all the way up
just nothing until oof into this
gorgeous room
with a couch this long purple couch and
a bar and in the middle of the purple
couch
was craig robinson with his towel over
his shoulder oh yeah just
girls
okay
okay
uh yeah i've got i'm going to um
i just brought up his our text thread
that we have and um
he is my second favorite people who like
uh keep passing on the show but in a
friendly way
jeff goldblum's amazing i have some
really funny text from him where he says
he wants to do but he can't um
i'm reading craigs that are really fun
because craig will say basically like
yeah i think i can do that yeah he'll
kind of float it out and then i follow
up and he's like nah like i'm not into
it
yeah but yeah yep uh i love him i
he's just one of the most honest um
until it comes to booking him
oh yeah yeah well yeah but yeah that's
honest he's just like it is just why did
people keep you hanging like they don't
want to seem like [ __ ] i feel like
the only thing only power we have in
this business is the power of no all
right like i have just told people like
i have don't have the bandwidth i am
yeah do not have it i'm so sorry
yeah hit me up in the spring or whatever
yeah are you able to do that are you
good at that uh yeah good sometimes i
mean i think it depends on my mood but
like yeah i can
i can do it i've i've been i'm not great
at it i'm a bit hard pleaser and a lot
of guilt uh yeah um but i've been saying
i've been
lately i find myself agreeing to things
uh
and i know in the back of my mind that a
half hour before the thing i'm not going
to want to do it
i have very little foresight um
but i so i i but it's you know obviously
in the pandemic during this time it's
one of the positives of all this it's
yeah
people don't have a lot of excuses right
now that's the thing yeah yeah so thanks
for doing this
yes is this podcast called no excuses
right yeah
really what it's called really what are
you doing um
by the way we should start recording
uh
i'm sorry i do that every time that's
stupid
where did you go to college did you go
to you're in boston umass you mass
amherst
oh i am hurst and and nate go up maybe
i'm getting that confused he went to uh
he went to uh what was it called colby
sawyer in new hampshire huh yeah he went
to a northeastern in in boston and
that's what he didn't like the size of
it he so he went to a small school where
he could
dominate the theater department
uh well he's a really good actor he's a
really good actor yeah were you guys
were you close growing up were you no
you must have been not at all
not at all i mean i grew up in boston
and
all my friends were like hey you gotta
start you gotta start toughening up your
little brother
right now
you gotta toughen them up
so i would be toughening him up whatever
that means
not understanding what the goal was like
why i had to toughen them up just that
my friends were like this is the
understanded
uh you know protocol
toughness
protocol i i toughened him up i mean by
ignoring him yeah oh and other stuff
he i tortured him man oh you're not
kidding but then we reached a point and
i think oh i thought you were i thought
that was uh a lock i was not doing a
lack i was it was uh not a lack that was
no kidding that was true
oh
really yeah
for the purposes of because it and i
i always forget you're from
massachusetts because you don't have but
did you grow up in a in a tough you grew
up in the suburb
yeah i grew up in the suburbs i mean i
wouldn't say it was like a tough
neighborhood but
you know all of the kids i went to
school with
they were like
one generation out of southie
uh-huh like their parents had made good
and got out
yeah you know so these guys these kids
my friends would go they had tough
parents yeah they would go back here
they would go back to southie for
thanksgiving or whatever and get the
[ __ ] beaten out of them because they
didn't live in southie and then they
would come back with a chip on their
shoulders so there was a lot of that i
think something like that some
some aspect of that i remember going to
this point you were i know and i want to
get to it you were both eagle scouts um
yeah and and my brothers and i we loved
boy scouts we were it was a really big
part of our our lives and uh but i
remember going to school i didn't know
you were uh i didn't know you were in it
well it's just i don't like to bring it
up because um
it's a big regret of my my brother my
little brother with whom i do the show
and my older brother both have their
eagle scout
uh but i dropped out right around the
time i was 13. so i was a really gung-ho
did you guys have the phrase joe scout
yes
yeah yeah yeah they would call me a joke
i was meaning
for the few of you who don't know what
that means um kind of like
it's that tool but like a really in a
really gung-ho
eager like an eager scout who just gets
all the badges that you just read
yes yes yeah yeah that's that
i got all the ones i would do like oh
extracurriculars basically the kid in
boy scouts who's like
teacher you forgot to give us homework
yeah we had a couple of those but but at
the second i discovered well i was
really girls yeah no 13 i mean obviously
uh i was lucky in that like our like
summer camps and stuff
girls were there
oh
families used to come and families of
the scouts would run the campsite oh
their daughters would come their sister
the scout sisters would come and i mean
my first girlfriend my first two
girlfriends were at
we're sisters of
my friends and boy scouts
yeah oh yeah well the biggest crush i
had was the a sister of the one kid in
our
uh troupe who was cool we had one cool
kid rich martin he was super cool and
like a jock and like kind of quiet and
like brooding and his sister was in my
class and i was in love with her and
they but they would only come on um
rob we went to yagoog do you remember
yaguki was a big camp in rhode island
there were kids from the boston area
that i remember being in like pawtucket
and like i remember pasco rhode island
as well you may have been just it may
have been mostly like northern rhode
island and like southern yeah i don't
know i may have just missed you but but
i remember the kids from that region
being extra i remember their accents
yeah and and them being like extra tough
and being extra intimidated bro yeah
they were intense like hey give me those
sneakers
yeah yeah sneakers
i just want to try them on i'm just
going to try them on give me your
sneakers totally you got a lot of more
yeah i am intimidating and it doesn't
have to like scary yeah i i so it's but
i don't i think of you as kind of the
opposite of that type of person so it's
uh it's amazing that you guys grew up
like that well you know i was i worked
in a restaurant in new york and one of
the busboys uh who had done time
for for dealing coke
told me i told them i always have
nightmares about going to prison and he
and he said oh you do great
he had spent like five years in prison
he told me i'd do great i was like why
would i do great in prison thinking he
was gonna say like you know because i
was feminine or something yeah yeah and
he said uh because you're funny oh
i have fewer nightmares about presents
and stuff that's interesting
i can see like how like a [ __ ] because
that's how i got along i just got along
with everybody i didn't have a set group
of friends but i got along with huh
and yeah you remind me a lot of my i
have yeah i'm sure you've met him john
togo did you know togo jonathan togo i i
think you might meet him on patriot bill
or whatever i [ __ ] you know
taking [ __ ]
doing some things
uh people people relating to one another
yeah
um
yeah but you but togo has that where i
think that was a big part of his
survival in that he grew up in a similar
environment his dad in fact was in
time and walpole and he's from rockland
mass and i i every time he meets
anyone from here
uh who's from harvard mass every time
you meet somebody like that uh he'll say
to them he doesn't drink anymore but one
night he goes um
he's set to cure yeah you get it kia
gets it he's from mass he gets it oh god
and so whenever
we i think about massachusetts people
from there i always think about togo
going he gets so the first quote my
brother writes these questions and he
goes from massachusetts he gets it
yeah do you find that when you
get it
yeah nate gets it yeah you find that in
la when you meet people from mass you
start kind of relating in a different
way oh i'm so excited when i meet
somebody from massachusetts we on i'm
shooting the unicorn right now oh right
and there's like um yeah two crew
members that are from massachusetts from
the bottom especially when it's a crew
member oh it's so great it's so great
and we just like
yeah oh yeah oh do you know you know the
sullivans you know yeah
oh [ __ ] it sully sullivan [ __ ] sully
dude let me tell you story about south
and then i'm like spitting all over them
yes yes
yeah that's the best i this is the
second third season of unicorn second
second uh well it should be the third
really second of uh of many second of
may i think it's gonna be 60 minutes of
uh oh wow and you already know you've
been they've been picked up for eight
i'm sure of it you can count on it yeah
well we love sound bites so i think
we're going to definitely go with that
one
for buzzfeed and that's a single camera
show michaela watkins
watkins goggins what a cast goggins you
know guys right uh yeah yeah well
rockwell every couple of years has a guy
that he falls in love with yes and wants
you to me i'm sure he's done it to you
yes you've got to meet yes
it was long yeah for a while it was well
when i was shooting um it was shooting
uh i was shooting hot tub too it was
like he and bib were like
you have got to meet
walton oh my god
these two together
about quarter you know
like and they were right yeah they were
they're right they're right that's right
yeah that's the thing he he loves
bringing people together but then it's
like well don't you know let us figure
it out we'll we might
he might like each other and and then
now go off
don't call us
get it
get out like you're her kid they're kids
yeah yeah uh they look at each other
proudly yeah exactly did you always
think you were going to your path was
going to be because you do great
impressions i'm now just realizing again
uh i focused basically on
classical [ __ ] in college oh wow i was
i was going to be i was shaking i was
going to be shakespeare in the park oh
no but i learned that like i didn't know
how to the one thing i didn't learn in
college was how to audition so
i i was basically doing shitty
shakespeare off off off broadway
and it was costing me money to do
and like
and i was
i was learning how to audition by just
going out on everything
even if it didn't like looking for a
female black lesbian
uh you know disabled uh
woman to play
yeah yeah i'm an actor i was like yep
yeah what yeah i don't care about
getting it i just want to practice oh
wow and robert did you have an agent at
the time were were these open calls
uh-huh no i didn't i didn't have an
agent until i got the daily show oh wow
these were backstage open calls wow wow
backstage for everyone was a magazine
where you could just yeah they had all
these yeah i think the unions
had to allow a certain amount of um
audition slots for just anyone and
people who didn't have representation
and uh they were usually like
you know usually kind of a long shot and
i my understanding is that they often
didn't take those actors as seriously um
but yeah i don't know i mean
i got a lot of like i said shitty
yeah [ __ ] yeah i like stuff to keep me
busy but to practice yeah yeah keep me
acting and but then
i i auditioned for a sketch group and i
got it
and i was like oh and now something made
me like do it have there been other
things that you flirted with doing uh
classical plays i've always wanted to do
the only i don't really care about doing
the state stage work but you must have
at some point i like it i i like it but
but also but i but i've got to pay the
bills oh yeah and i've got you know a
steady job and i've got to do that so
did that come from your parents were
your parents very practical with stuff
like that where they're like actor you
want to be actor but both no no they
were very they didn't give a [ __ ] they
didn't even say don't ask me for money
no kidding they were like
actually my dad was very practical he
was like i wanted to be an artist when i
was really young and he was like well
you can be a commercial artist let me
show you this they showed me a flyer
like a circular from the newspaper
back when they used to draw the bicycles
oh yeah you know
at bradley's or sears
did he really yeah he started out
drawing a commercial artist commercial
artist as in in um i didn't know
periodicals and stuff yeah he would draw
for like advertisements and stuff far
out well that's like
what my dad was like trying to take my
particular passion at the time
and make it practical right you know
interesting um they were brought up and
i was sort of brought up in this world
where
it wasn't a real thing that yeah art
world like yeah do that yeah leave and
go and pursue that
yeah it was it's an odd thing it was an
odd thing for me to choose
to me as well it just wasn't uh a
profession i mean it's i think there are
movie stars and some people did it
obviously no yeah you can't do that
these are other these are people were
born movie stars yes
theater stars and they just were doing
that their whole lives
yeah i was born over here yeah academy
ave uh yeah south weymouth uh yeah and
yeah so
i'd never i never
really thought it was a real thing at
what point did it become i mean you
mentioned so you're waiting tables and
you're pursuing it you're actively
pursuing you're going on all these crazy
auditions at that point are you thinking
what it what do you what's the plan is
it to become a stage actor is it to
become uh to make a living doing it it
was just to make a living it was just
like my i think i my
my idea of what my understanding of what
um success is
has changed over the years and it kept
changing and it's still always changing
like
yeah i never
back in college
i remember telling this this is so
embarrassing it's cringy i remember
telling this
woman
a really good friend of mine that like
she was like what do you want to do and
i was like i don't know but i know i'm
going to be famous
and now i i said that now i remember
saying that it's so gross
i so respect that you admitted that
saying that not
with any aspirations to fame
like i didn't i don't give a [ __ ] i
didn't give a [ __ ] about it but i knew
like
that was gonna and so because i think i
think subconsciously i knew i was gonna
be an actor yeah and i i i was i was
aggressively confident about
irritability that's right well you must
have been because you are good i imagine
you were good um and you have to be
there's got to be a degree of confidence
when you're right and in college you
don't have that that [ __ ] button
right that sensor in your head going
right you know that's something that you
should just think keep to yourself and
not say that you're going to be
you know and certainly don't say it
famous
right certainly don't say it in like an
ominous potentially creepy way because
it could mean like i'm going to be
famous for murdering something i said it
like this i said it like this i'm going
to be famous
is that ominous
but it's still weird okay it's still
murder adjacent all right i'm not sure i
can't tell i can't tell from here from
this angle
um yeah it's really funny
i i've gotta wonder um you mentioned
being on the receiving end of that
somebody's saying that oh you know what
i know i remember her name was bethany
and she's super smart and she went like
this she went
like knowing knowingly like
not like
it's not that you're definitely not
going to be famous but you're just like
that was
that was uh
yeah it was [ __ ] aggressive that was
a mistake
yeah i like you so i'm going to let it
go but like one day you're going to look
back at that listen you've got this is
breaking news i've never admitted that
this is it's great anyway you know i i i
suppose i don't remember myself well
enough at the time but i do remember
fetishizing
uh being an actor you know
like
wanting it for the quote-unquote you
know the wrong reasons and and i was i
remember being into like there was that
vanity fair cover where all the young
the new guys are the new actors
they would put out like ulrich and like
yeah i remember thinking like oh how
cool are they you know that they're like
i was aware of like the next thing and
yeah it's funny i
might same thing my perception of
success is really like yeah dramatically
so it changes it changes i did this like
year-long tour for the national
shakespeare company which sounds a lot
more impressive than it is my brother
did that no i know i know it's not he's
a company of shakespeare yeah so it does
sound impressive but it's like you play
like high schools and stuff oh yeah you
know you're just doing laundry the whole
time yes
in a van you're trying i didn't know
that i didn't know my older brother
that's insane i've met your brother i
met my little brother it's it's my older
brother but now a teacher but yeah he
did i know
yeah so like um
so yeah i did that and and i was sitting
on stage once and there was a time we
were all on stage the whole time and all
playing different parts
and i i was just sitting down getting
fed you know imaginary grapes
that i happen to be dating on the tour
you know like for love of course and of
course and yeah and i was like looking
out at the the lights and everything and
i was like i made it
i did it i made it
and i had
i had made it yes yes by the way i
learned so much that night like
if you could keep doing that like what
is your what is your version of i've
made it you know
and like right now i'm feeding my family
you know we just had to
fix something in my backyard that
because it was broken
if i can do that
and if my family's happy right and and
i'm and i've got a job that i go to
practically nine to five then i made it
i i i bet i bet i've i know i'm about to
change i totally was helping my brother
older brother move something he's a
three-year-old and a one-year-old and i
was and the three-year-old loves when i
read to him and it is more flattering to
me
when he's like i choose you to read me
the bedtimes or over my mother who's a
great reader over so he sits on my lap
and he keeps he is desperate to keep
reading and another one and
for me to read and it is
i i found myself having to hold back uh
like of course having just keep from
weeping i almost started weeping right
now yeah like that is that is the best
you made it you made it life could be a
dream sweetheart
[Music]
[Music]
and i'm about to go off and do this
acting job and i've been like jonesing
to to do it you know i i'm so miss
acting and what
and i'm now wondering
well do i is it going to be as
fulfilling as it was is it going to be
the same kind of fulfilling
yeah i'm tell me about that what do you
mean like you know what it is it's going
back to the hotel room and finding the
robs and the gears and like i don't
think we can do that anymore but like
i just don't know if i'll get the same
kind of kick from it you know like yeah
but it's i've been i've been doing i did
i've done two shows since this thing
started and oh wow it's been very
it makes the whole thing
i've just we've worked three weeks into
the unicorn and i've just started
enjoying myself
and i love this show i love it yeah
i love it and
it's just been it's been not um
not fun
what is it that what's the first thing
that prevents the fun is it is it the
missing your family is like no [ __ ]
yeah i mean they're right there i'm at
paramount man i'm 20 minutes away oh
like right yeah no that'll yeah i'll be
back at six but like it's really like so
this is a personal thing i i hate
wardrobe i hate putting a mic on
like my it sets a fire in my brain
that like all the mic is starting to
travel over my knee
i could feel it as i'm walking and it's
taking me out of the scene and i'm like
this this will eliminate 95 maybe 98 of
the listening whoever's listening now
but but what what is your preference
whenever they're like you know that
they're like mild-mannered sound guys
like what do you want uh where do you
want the mic pack oh
left ankle inside oh left ankle inside
yeah oh i go right ankle inside yeah
yeah yeah uh but it's but so it took
three weeks but then you when you settle
back in is it like
it just playing around with friends now
is that the the level that you you've
reached with
i don't know we just had a great episode
this week and i and i had two i was in
two scenes that like
felt like the old days it felt like oh
wow this is i felt i felt like we really
made this scene something else
and i and they let you improvise oh yeah
yeah oh that's great but there's such
good writers that i don't yeah i don't
need to it's just at the end you know
why isn't that the best
place to yeah oh and then we also just
you know we can make it your own if if
it doesn't quite fit into your mouth
like apparently yeah yeah
like yeah yeah i'll change a couple
words but
um i like the way they write so i don't
i i don't know how you felt about it but
i i that's my favorite place to
improvise from when it's good when it's
already good you've already got a good
thing and you can maybe
you know you can you can add to it but
um on the thing we did i remember
feeling the pressure of having to and i
wonder if you felt of having to
kind of
do more you know of having to kind of
like make some of this yes uh oh my god
yeah yeah oh my god yes i remember
and i remember
feeling like that that you and nick
offerman
as well was okay yeah
yes he sure was yeah yes you do nick off
from him
yeah
oh we
are
are we allowed to improvise i can't now
i like oh that's i started thinking
about it too much i started yeah yeah i
can't do it and uh
really
wanting to be able to like re you know
rise to
yours and nicks
oh god i felt the same thing
uh with with improvising on oh cause i
had done only a few movies before that
that's crazy rob i thought that was i
felt that about you keira and i were
really like oh my god he's the master
he's the
oh my god that's not funny no no no i
never feel like the master right i've
always been so that it was
wow it was daily show i mean it was
because that's what i think of his daily
show is all that daily show is pure when
you do those oh yeah well the field
pieces sure yeah yeah but it was also
very um
structured improv
like you know we would cut and then i
would wish the producer would whisper to
me and i'd be like okay
you know or or i would come up with
something but
yeah so you're sitting there for four
hours and you're like i don't know
i'm just going to ask the questions man
it's taking a long time
and and did we talk about the apple
commercials did we talk about you may be
doing are you going to do those yeah we
never i don't think i've ever because i
didn't know this
at the time
who told you you know i don't know
actually i'm trying to remember whether
it was
phil the director oh
phil i know phil
it may have been phil that that so for
people wondering what we're talking
about yeah you were going to
do it i was thinking you would know
hodgman's part yeah yeah and um i don't
remember why i didn't you found out i
was doing it or because i found what
you're doing
i uh i i don't know i don't remember
like
i i think
i don't know i don't remember i well i
just didn't do it oh
it was also because i was
cut because i was playing the pc
yeah i was like [ __ ] that
i'm not [ __ ] pc man
that's what i heard yeah it's something
that's what that that that's funny
well it's funny rob because i must have
told you this the first i must have told
you this because the first the way they
presented that job to me
was um
i mean we were both there again i was
like well i don't do commercials you
know and now of course i'd be like
please can i have a question yeah
yeah but at the time it was like oh i'm
doing these movies and these it was a
different time
is it different yeah but they they told
me that the way they they led with
okay i mean you were one of like part of
this like the thing they presented as
being like this is kind of this could be
a cool thing it was like rob cordrey is
doing it and i thought oh they said i
was doing it yeah i was never doing it
yeah that's funny that's fine i was a
fan of yours so i was like okay i'm
listening if you know they got that um
but yeah that's
such a tactic like yeah if i'm talking
about it my lawyers are talking about it
with them they're like all right he's
doing it as far as we're concerned rob
corey is doing it justin
i i did a play a steve martin play in
san diego and um i'm so glad i did it
but he had written the play and they
were like the writer will be
workshopping the plane we'll be working
on it every day they were really
specific about
the writer being there and i thought
oh to be around just to be in a room
it was like done so i signed up for this
thing
he the director basically tells us all
like you know steve because i was like
oh i'll just ask steve when he comes and
he's like oh yeah he's not cut he oh he
might pop in like once he didn't he came
to one performance when we're home
and so on the first night we all went
out well or some night we were all out
and uh donald faison was in the in the
show and and um my friend phil and we
were all one by one we kind of admitted
that like that was a big reason why we
all did it oh do you guys think steve is
gonna be here
yeah my agent told me that too we were
all so grateful to have done it but yeah
well you know in terms of this you know
the apple commercial
i'm when i saw them
you know and then i kept seeing them and
kept seeing them kept saying and they
were good commercials
you know
uh
you know part of me of course was like
oh [ __ ]
but i also realized they would not have
been
what they were with me and them because
hodgman
hodgman brought
an energy to it that like
i would
never even get close to and so i don't
know if they would have been as good
with me in them i think they got the
right guy for sure well i i i i'm a huge
fan of both of yours and and you know
it's hard for me to talk about because i
no i want you to pick one of us right
now
me or hodgman go
go
it's uh
are we are you breaking up here because
i'm getting a weird sound thing nope
we're on a boat we're on a boat and
there's you have to throw one of us off
chuck [ __ ] mary
uh okay what is your most commonly used
emoji would you say your go-to you use
it more than any others i'm not a big
emoji guy but i have used um ironically
used uh the uh
was it like a beaver swimming upside
down oh there is an otter oh yeah it's a
new one otter otter the otter is going
upside down i don't know what it's
supposed to mean but i just heard that
like hey
whatever this means like yeah chew on
this answer okay that's fine
if you could be a professional athlete
uh what sport would you play you guys
were big basketball uh baseball i would
play uh baseball i would be a pitcher i
would be the best i'd be the [ __ ]
best oh okay all right well that wasn't
part next question
the socks right i mean for sure yeah
[ __ ] socks no yes sorry i'm not yeah
getting traded to [ __ ] l.a like
[ __ ] mookie
oh [ __ ] bad sound can bet's curse
there's going to be a bet's curse dude
mark my words
my what words what is the what's the
best what what's the most common when
people try boston what do they what do
they lean too far into
what is the r's are they stress the r
the lack of ours but they
you know there's a subtlety because
they'll add you know boston people add
ours at the end like i'm gonna go yeah
i'm gonna go get a pizza
and i'm gonna go with linda
you know yeah yeah yeah also it's also
like this uh
like that
it's kind of an irish tea it's better
it's like
yes it's almost a row some words are
rolled the tea is rolled a little bit
better
who does a really good one i heard
renner's in the town is really good yeah
oh well yeah yeah
yeah but like like robin williams in um
in a good way hunting
not great
well he doesn't really attempt which is
crazy because i talk about i mean
i i don't i remember thinking he's not
really
going for it yeah it's all over the
place it's all about huh
it's a hard accent it's a really hard
accent it is right because people dean
is the had they kind of pushed that the
yeah yeah and they get all mixed up with
new york and long island and you know
yeah god i think that's the only time
i've ever said anything less than like
glowing about robin williams on um
he knows i love him and i was enjoying
it yeah
um if you could have dinner with uh what
what did you what's your favorite movie
of all time rob or one that you you were
really excited to to show your kids you
know arthur
ow
dudley moore yeah yeah my wife bought me
that movie once for my birthday because
she likes to watch me watch it
oh that's yeah one of the most romantic
things i've ever heard it's it's it's
the bag right i've watched it recently i
watched it all the time wow that's when
you know you love somebody when you're
really excited to see them enjoy
something yeah right yeah that's cool uh
if you could have one snack food for the
rest of your life
what would it be your go-to your stone
you're just terrance so i've smoked some
[ __ ]
uh yeah some guns legit some j's
yeah
i've been choking it i've been taking
some james
yeah
[ __ ]
dude
snack food i like sour cream and onion
uh ruffles
oh yeah yeah
yeah i think that's what it is yeah okay
um oh yes uh if uh you had to live
somewhere else where would it be oh i
was i don't know man probably yeah yeah
i like
i don't i don't know why sonoma comes
into my head because that's weird i've
only been there once
you must have loved it i loved it i
loved it i like anywhere where there's
like big big trees big thick trees uh
yeah i also like vancouver that whole
anywhere north of here on the west like
yeah somewhere around there
um
who is your if you could have dinner
with three people dead or alive whom
you've never met oh i don't like going
to dinner oh okay all right a brunch um
oh oh that's not that's different
um
people people alive are dead yes never
met oh man i'd like to like just pick
the i'd like to
absorb them a little bit and socialize
stephen king
i heard i have met him but it was a i
blew it uh vince i just talked to
vince's i said that he's one that was
one of his three get out of here really
yeah yeah it was or uh yeah who would
you say george orwell stephen king and
kubrick yeah stephen king um
david lynch
oh yeah and david mitchell the guy that
wrote cloud atlas oh wow uh yeah
okay uh that's a hell of a tennis that's
two days only men two davids davidson
two david's one stephen that's how i oh
it could have been any
davidson
i don't even know their work
well you love names
do you have other siblings rob is it
just you and nate uh we have a sister
named laura yeah oh okay she's not is
she not a no did she have anything she's
uh she's in she works in higher
education in massachusetts
then i'm not interested
um if
if you uh who's your favorite muppet did
you have a favorite muppet growing up oh
yeah um oh growing up
or whenever or or as an adult i have a
favorite one it's uh the guy that who's
the guy that plays piano oh ralph
ralph yeah i did the muppet movie
and i got cut i got cut oh wow and
i was walked back and there was all
these muppets now it was a theater
environment and i walked backstage i
look out and there i'm supposed to come
back on but wait a beat to come back on
and rolf goes like this
rob is leaning around his screen and
staring at you you know that's really
like and he's waiting for me and i went
oh my god oh my god these are real it's
a human yeah yeah yeah yeah so i like uh
and i also i i sort of like brought out
with him too we hung around he gets like
the puppeteers like to get dirty oh yes
yes i did a brief thing with bedford and
they were like it's just but like
inappropriately oh you don't have to
yeah
they're so sick of being like you know
safe
um if you could be uh reincarnated as a
non-human animal what would you pick an
animal that you'd you'd want to be oh
wow well you think i would say what did
vince font say uh you know i don't think
i asked him that i think we were in too
much of a hurry and i was trying to get
to
i think i skipped that one i would think
a big cat
oh yeah vince would be a good big cat
i think i think i would be big oh yeah
yeah
uh because i'm so i'm already like very
live
yeah you have like
your life but you also have some mass to
you you have some i have massive muscle
yeah you have a lot of sinui um yeah
would you rather be called unattractive
or unfunny unattractive oh yeah
oh yeah yeah i call myself unattractive
every day i'm so used to it that's yeah
it's so funny yeah i've heard it's yeah
um yeah i don't care about that which uh
which golden girl do you most identify
with dorothy blanche rose or sophia i
don't
yeah
man
listen you got about the golden girls i
don't you don't care it's my wife loves
the golden girls
i bought her for her birthday for her
birthday i bought her a floor plan of
their apartment
what like she's that into it oh my god
she would start randomly when the kids
were little randomly when we were eating
go
thank you for being a friend
so i think i would be a mod what's her
what oh dorothy yeah blanche
because she's always kind of the closest
you get to like
yeah looking at the camera
yes yes
you would love the show it's a brilliant
uh
um
bunch of old ladies
yes
sassy and smart
sassy old ladies
dogs uh dogs are cats you prefer
cats cats yes you kind of audience
beetles are the rolling stones
beetles and you have a song that like uh
your your go-to you could play any of
them
yeah well the the second side of abby
road oh yeah kind of like golden
slumbers and all that uh yeah boy you're
gonna carry that majesty but also her
majesty like i would say and yeah that
sort of chunk yeah the second side yeah
it's the thing i test my new record
players or record record needles with uh
that's a good question by the way that's
a good question yes you asked that it's
interesting some people like mullen for
example was like oh stones of course you
did and i would i would have guessed
marlon yeah yeah yeah because i like the
stones i understand it but it's blues
yeah and it's all blue people with some
sort of rock background who who i think
perform themselves are like yeah yeah um
yeah well i uh man i selfishly i could
keep you on for
another hour and a half well good nope i
have a
a series of questions asked oh great
okay
they're not fun they're like
oh really it's like no one's going to
want to listen well what i was going to
say i'd like to do it but i have a
limited amount on my uh shot first
oh oh there's the sharpest hands in the
in the catch room you said what did you
say
just because the gatron's in in i'm just
missing that one
uh
i said i'm sorry because the cause and
then
it's the gatrons and on the flitz the
gap trends it's on the flitz so i gotta
go because it's on the plate the first
you said oh it's on the fridge well only
well
no it's joshua
get it you're from mass
um
you get it yes brought it back yes
brought it back
that's why you're one of the greats
you didn't know i had a podcast till
yesterday um
uh buddy you're the best i you're the
best thank you for doing this i love you
i'm so glad you asked me to do this uh
thank you
really great catching up all right man
thanks
so
that happened so that happened
that's your impression
yeah he kind of does yeah he kind of
does yeah that's a little like marty
mcfly though i know too much maybe oh i
guess i have more i often have him on my
brain but uh we were talking about time
machine
time machines that's a fun part of that
movie is like they don't really
care about the inner work they kind of
make a joke about the technicalities
that's the funny story of how he talked
about getting the script for it and he
was like oh god like
[ __ ] my career you know he got the
script this is the worst and then he
read it and i feel it it was like the
the sub
title to it was like based on the truest
story ever so yeah and he's like
yeah uh he's very funny isn't he funny
very dry
yeah and he's like mastered sarcasm you
know that like very easy
sarcastic tone yeah i feel like he could
teach if they're if that were a class
taught at like the distance you should
be a starcast and professor
yes yeah
uh and when you when he you enter his
class he's like oh i'm so excited to
teach you
um that curb story is funny that uh
and
interesting that they
tell people not to try to be funny i
know it makes sense it makes perfect
sense but just my own tastes like the
ones that i can see trying to be funny
it's not nearly as fun i know and lately
that's a good rule of thumb for anything
i know for any comedy comedy don't try
to be funny yeah trust the material
because the situation itself is funny i
don't know if it's easy to do i think
it's easy for some people but it's hard
i'm sure it's hard to do it really well
because it means you have to be a really
good actor what means you really do you
just have to commit it's just about
i feel like this is like a this is beard
into like a pretentious actor podcast
you just commit to the material but it
really is all that's all it is i think
you think about your favorite
performances and i'm thinking about a
lot of robs where he's like he also gets
away with a lot of re he does ridiculous
things in movies like he says ridiculous
things children's hospital is absurd
it's an absurd premise for a show yes
but he
commits to that he's a good example of
that like if you commit you can get away
with it yeah i feel like that show the
premise of that show could only come
from his brain you know like the
combination of like that some really
really dark material but but making it
funny and and delivering it in a natural
dry way yeah just joking around with him
it brought me back to that shooting that
movie together in south carolina did you
guys go out a lot during that yeah we
did
he wasn't on it for that long he had a
family so he was going back and forth he
did he came in for a little bit but like
yeah and with offerman and
emmanuel i i mean here and i we mostly
it was mostly the two of us
but
rob was around for some but i remember
going to um
a uh a chain restaurant that catered to
um
well families and um
they had an owl mascot okay i know
you're talking about yeah
they're not a sponsor yet of the show no
but who knows who who knows
god
i went to one of those restaurants in
connecticut when i was
like 15 years old
you feel really naughty with our parents
get out of here i never told you that no
yeah you went to hooters
yeah you did yeah it was i was going to
an appointment
even though there was one here it was up
in like weathersfield or something
upstate because i was going to i had
this back doctor where this field it
sounds like such a pretentious
but it's not a pretentious place you
must go to the hooters and with a sphere
or just it is to die
their wings are divine but i remember i
was 14
i think 14 or 15.
and they were driving me
from this appointment
and i fell asleep in the car
and i woke up to my to our dad saying
okay we're here get out of here and i
swear and i like you know opened my eyes
blurry eyes and i and i looked out the
car window and we were in the parking
lot of a hooter was i not there you
weren't there it was just three of us
good because how would i forget this and
and to cap it off it was on holy
thursday
what yeah
what did mom say was she like he was
like okay and paul was like they've got
great wings here you know he had
somebody
so we went in they do have so
uncomfortable because
you know it's not a place you want to be
with your parents
no
no
it's not a place i mean i have to it's
not really a place i ever want to be i
know but because i feel uncomfortable i
do feel like i feel if i'm in there
people assume i'm a pervert well that
and also like then i feel whatever we
sound like too like apologetic you know
guys but like i always do feel bad for
the girls but it's like they they're
they're you know their work i don't know
it's like i'm not saying i've had a lot
of fun at those places i shouldn't feel
bad necessarily yeah but i have a guilty
pleasure i know me too me too and i do
feel bad me too but i definitely don't
think i should but they show the games
there they got the beer and like ah you
don't have to sell me on i think there's
a lot of great ways
yeah
great things about it again they're not
no but you never know based on this
conversation they might want to be a
sponsor and maybe if they were to be a
sponsor we would be less shy about
talking about our yeah for sure the good
times we've had there sure if if we were
to get a gift certificate to go there
let's say yes i think we would sing a
different tune yeah even if it was like
a free
uh basket of wings with every uh
they have pretty good food there they do
they have those you know they have like
this the popcorn shirt yes those are
good yeah man
um you asked away from the vaccine you
asked him if um
david wayne was still involved with
children's hospital and he told you that
the show wasn't on tv anymore
and
yes
and you um
artfully got out of it and you were
self-deprecating about it but it was a
really funny moment
i first been off the air for a couple
years i didn't know that
i thought we were just talking to mullin
about it former uh
we were talking about how she had been
on it yeah all right well i mean because
that's that's the difficulty with
streaming not to defend myself i i hate
that i just became one of those people
who can't admit that they're wrong i'm
wrong i'm wrong about it obviously well
it was our research department that was
really to blame that's true oh it was
written if it was written i'll read it
i'll bergan do that but uh i you know
there's with all the streaming things
it's like it's hard to remember because
things just seem on right now like like
portland has been off the air for three
years i think but as far as i'm
concerned it's like you turn on netflix
it's right there that's true yet you
knew that they weren't still making new
episodes when you talked right fred i
did yeah i watched so it's a tough
comparison to make because it it must
have right away he must have known if he
thought about it long enough well he
definitely knew you weren't a huge fan
of the show yeah that's for sure but you
like all those people i like the people
and whenever i've seen this yeah me too
i really enjoy it it's really fun it was
on forever it was on for like he doesn't
need me to be knowledgeable but it would
have been respectful if you had done
some research
um speaking of research uh
both
what
you know both have to not have seen your
children's hospital been enjoyed every
time it's on um his brother nate
is an eagle scout as as is he yeah and
um you brought that up and
you weren't an eagle scout but that's
okay you made it really far and you kept
referring to me as
your little brother in throughout the
interview and uh i think
it's time to retire that i don't think
you can call me that anymore
little brother uh yeah i think once
you're once we're adults which we have a
while first of all i'm not i'm bigger
than you for one thing and also
i'm in my late 30s i guess so didn't he
call nate his little brother i don't
think so baby because i think he is
would you prefer baby brother
baby brother you know baby brother makes
more sense to me in a weird way
because yeah
because everyone knows i'm not a baby
so that's obvious if you call me your
baby brother
but your little brother it's it's
misleading in a couple ways because i'm
not little i just thought that dave
bautista is somebody's baby brother
isn't that funny it would be funny if
you had an older brother who was like
shrimpy yes
it would that's a movie
yeah it's twins yeah yeah
um yeah is that the whole joke in twins
is that they just look so different
no they're also they're also a very
different person personally right he
he's like very noble right yeah
devito is like corrupt he's like yeah
he's like a grifter he's like i'm not
all the [ __ ] that didn't go into you i'm
like the yeah he's like the kind of
crap schwarzenegger's the uh good one
he's yeah that's a really good movie i i
want to rewatch it now
um it's amazing though they haven't
remade that does that seem like a movie
that they would have
the rock is kevin hart
yeah exactly yeah i know maybe they did
i bet it was in development or something
they never
or happened or they just couldn't get
the rights to that name or something and
it turned into another video
wait what were you so so okay i'll
retire little brother um i really liked
his favorite emoji do you remember what
it was uh you know i don't a beaver
swimming upside down
oh yeah it's an otter
it's pretty funny yeah hopefully they
can find that when they put the little
picture of uh yeah
um let's read a letter that's how fun
that's see quick mind funny not mine and
now it's gonna be funny in
print to see that yeah the podcast thing
smart yeah letter i don't know if they
had that those uh
beavers this is a letter from this is
the letter from
maya becker i've been seeing a lot of
interesting um spellings for word names
that i thought i could spell
m-a-i-y-a
maya maya subject would you rathers
greetings chestnut and christian i wrote
you a while back about being a new
shorty and catching up on past episodes
i'm a few episodes in on the quarantine
ones and thought i'd share some would
you rather's for a couple years on
facebook i asked a weekly would you
rather question my friends and these
were the most hotly debated oh cool
that's great so she has like a lot to
call cull through a lot of episodes no
no but a lot of would you rather stu
with her friend she had a weekly
uh would you rather also yeah she'll
have a launch she'll have a lot to go
through before she gets to this episode
she's so lucky oh wow
she'll be able to binge it all
would you rather give up eating give up
eating all vegetables for fruit or
give up all fruit for vegetables oh i
think we've
parameters a tomato is a vegetable
uh-huh we've talked about this before
and so is an avocado but tomatoes
shouldn't be mentioned well for the sake
of that okay
play by the fruit salad method and not
the scientific classification okay
gotcha mine you're right i shouldn't
what whatever that's just squirm army
response sure was maybe technique
uh give up eating all vegetables
i thought about this before i would give
up fruit i really like fruit a lot but i
rely more on batch vegetables vegetables
that was afraid slip i have a smoothie
every morning
and that means i wouldn't have be able
to have that
vegetables are healthier than fruit i i
think right just because there's much
less sugar in them also the fact that
she's including tomatoes in there as a
vegetable that helps that cause yeah i
eat a lot of like tomato based oh yeah
even ketchup and avocado and you get
avocados yeah
vegetables pair well
with pineapple and meals set upon and no
it wasn't it was pun unintended
it pairs well with uh
food like meals but the fruit yeah i'd
be giving up would be affect my dessert
life yeah although not dessert life
though although i gotta say and i'd
rather
skimp on the dessert if i had to because
i it's better for you exactly and you
want to live longer because you like
life there are other aspects of life
you'd rather savor exactly like
vegetables i do like fruit though a lot
and i love fruit like fruit candy fruit
desserts it would be tough to give but
but i don't juice but that doesn't mean
you give up those it would it's fruit
you're not you wouldn't give up a
skittle i think it's got like a degree
of friendship in my mind i'd have to
give up skittles as part of this yeah
wow well you know i've been one of my
resolutions is to um not indulge as much
in uh
thc
and so i do want to but i enjoy weed and
so i want to find a healthier way of
snacking and last night i gotta say i i
tore into a honey crisp apple
not a sponsor
um and god was it good it was really
satisfying but i do that so rarely you
know fruit yeah
definitely vegetables for me
is that it yeah no no there's another
one there are two more if you only had
to you like these right are you excited
for the next one i like the first one if
you only have to choose one and give up
the other two permanently would you
choose to keep books music or
tv movies theater wait wait books and
books and music start together yeah yeah
if you had to choose one and give up the
other to
oh no i'm sorry and give up the other
two permanently so you choose one of
these
tv movies theater altogether i think so
it's books
music
or tv movies theater parameters you
can't sing to yourself there's no music
in movies whoa
can't tell stories etc hmm
wow
wait i don't get to tell stories why not
why wouldn't she be able to that's not
necessarily
theater or movies that that's that's not
unique to that art can you read the
beginning again i feel like if you might
have if you only had to choose one and
give up the other two permanently oh i
see okay so the three of them
are what are the three these are three
one books okay two music three tv movies
theater
okay and i can only keep one of those
three uh i would yeah but here's the
thing if you can't tv tv and
movies and a lot of theater
music is such an important component i
know
i would keep
[ __ ] can you listen to a book on tape
ooh she hasn't probably not probably no
she says you can't tell story that one's
confusing me too can't tell stories
that's
so you can't have any sort of oratory
entertainment you know i
i
i want to say books because i think it's
the most important of those for a
well-rounded life but i think that music
i think i would pick music i think i
would too
even though of all those things i
probably music is probably the smallest
component of tv is probably the biggest
yeah but i don't but i'm
i'm thinking aspirationally yeah
the books would be
i know i wish i could say
books are too important a part of my
life but unfortunately they should be
i give up music that's a tough one maya
would you rather give up the need for
sleep or the need to eat the need for
sleep or the need to eat primers if you
choose to give up sleep you can't sleep
recreationally and same goes for food if
you choose food you don't get to eat
enough so it's like if they weren't uh
essential if they weren't oh definitely
mine's easy i would give up sleep me too
yeah
and that because you get more done
yeah and if you don't need it it would
be kind of great yeah and you could
still um sure you'd be like diddy you
can still like check out
for a while yeah and like
no just close your eyes and lie down and
remove yourself right in whatever
situation presumably it wouldn't be
frustrating to not be able to say except
you're not able to oh that's easy if you
don't need to rather yeah easy in fact
that'd be cool
um thanks for all the love and then back
to maya thanks for all the laughs
especially when you two debated the
merits of bringing your brother on your
dates versus calling out their name
during sex
yeah
i hope damien didn't listen to that it
wasn't about him it's about you yeah oh
right i think no he was mentioned in it
i think he was
well hopefully he's not listening to
this i was crying from laughing so hard
thanks my
maya becker um p.s i'm making another
batch of cannabis caramel soon huh
holler if you want some i want some
yeah
oh she didn't say holla she said holler
uh
thank you yeah and thanks for hollering
at us i wish that were part of my
vernacular oh that's a cool if you said
that casually it would be really funny
sounding uh thanks for having me let me
try i don't know
all right
uh say you're leaving
and um
you're gonna you're going to trader
joe's
and uh you want to say let me know if
you need anything okay
um okay uh i'm i'm heading out i'm going
to trader joe's holler at me if you need
anything
that's not bad it's not terrible but you
hit the r way too hard caller holler out
how would you say it let me try uh hey
uh where are you going you're leaving
i'm just going to the store what do you
where i'm going trader joe's oh okay
yeah well how are you no holler if you
need anything holler howler if you need
anything you go holla
i'm trying to be casual i know i know
you're doing that thing where uh uh like
certain actors we know they do
fake scratches oh yeah that's one of my
favorites in interviews yeah appear
i love a good fake scratch everyone be
on the lookout for that when you see
an actor talking about something that
they don't really maybe care about uh
they'll scratch their face in a fake
face or or pull on their ear a little
bit yeah any version of that's their
hair yeah the back of their head is sure
that move of course yeah
yeah it's to appear casual
it's such the best it's such a great
move and it's a great move but once
you're aware of it once you like are
dialed into it it's you see it all the
time
fake fake touches and stuff oh yeah out
of a couple right now uh well thank you
anyway thank you maya for your letter
though yeah really that was good those
were good would you rather good would
you rather those were and thanks for the
offer for the uh caramels and i like
that it's very nice it helps to have
some parameters yeah it was thoughtful
it's pretty well thought out makes me
want to enjoy fruit while i can you know
go have a nice piece of fruit well you
this is not coming true i know but part
of the things with would you rather you
start you imagine it you imagine it yeah
so then you appreciate them more that's
true
um anyway we appreciate all you guys
listening yeah if you want to play
myself i say we're pretty good it's very
2021
if you guys want to write in our email
address is life is short at wondery.com
and uh thank you to the wonderful more
than just a funny baldman
yes he's a sweetman too nice very good
very kind clever intelligent yeah
brilliant funny person yes thanks rob
thanks for being on and um so fun to
catch up with him and
thanks to all of you for listening to
our catch-up uh
and thanks to christian my uh brother my
younger brother yes young i thought i
was not supposed to say that you're a
little little yeah younger brother oh
god
and um thanks to all of you
little people
or big people or anything in between we
might have some little people listeners
and fake people listen yes we like them
all
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
uh you've been listening to life is
short i'm your host life is short is
hosted by me justin long it's co-hosted
by
uh younger brother christian long it's
also produced by megan monaco megan
monaco senior producer is michelle
lans audio engineer is sergio enriquez
and on this one we've got two executive
producers here they are marcia louis and
hernan lopez for wondering
[Music]
but the thing about carrie uh underwood
is that she
she
i think i don't know if that could
happen again i don't know if like
somebody with her talent and her charm
the farm girl like that could be just
discover because i feel like they would
have there's so many different avenues
now
on which to be in which to be discovered
it takes something like that
she might have been the last because
she's exceptional like she's like a fine
ass like un like fine yeah in our
country like the last one yeah
because that was right before a social
media pool right after kelly clarkson so
p it had been legitimized a little bit
by kelly clarkson and
and then this like she had this
she was beautiful she was
she's she's amazing i never realized how
great carrie underwood is oh i was such
a big fan i always did but like she's
really
i don't think i wonder if that's going
to be discovered they won't find someone
like that again
you